we met years and years and years ago on
Senate live right we were well we were
both working there both writers there
and then you run for Senate and the
whole time that you're running for
Senate and then after becoming a senator
it felt like you didn't really get a
chance to be funny you know what I mean
yet you you had to restrain you can't
you can't
especially you can't do physical humor
okay right and your puny guy you're a
very funny guy and I spent years with
this guy and you're a very funny person
but you had to suddenly rein it in no
physical comedy nothing no physical
comedy like that thing you do with the
legs that's not bad
let me say what is this just right here
I could I do this if I was a senator no
you couldn't do the thing where you're
going a c-span cameras there and I
chipped my tooth you couldn't do that
you can't do that no it's like a cat can
you do that I got a hearing ya know get
up and wave my ass
can I do that is that something you can
do no okay you know that's exactly why
you shouldn't be a senator and there are
more reasons than that I'm serious yeah
because you know I've known you for all
these years and and you too I used to I
want to start you know 23 years ago and
what you do I mean making people laugh
the way you do and the you're now the
Dean of late-night TV
he's a Dean he's been here as long as
and I just want you guys to know that do
not for one second think that what you
do is less important than what I do even
though it is it's nice it's really nice
of you to say
it's what I've learned is that you what
you do for a living is much more
important than what I do is but Andy you
would leave here immediately and go and
get a waffle somewhere oh right back to
my Christmas tree farm this is the most
depressing conversation I've had in a
while
you